[リ] はいどーも、アバンティーズのリクヲと、
[エ] エイジと、
[は] こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです！！（かすれ声
[エ] （笑）
[は] 風邪でちょっと喉がおかしいんですけども
[は] やっぱり、風邪をひくと何が大事だと思いますか？
[リ] ぷぷっ（笑
[は] おはは、お前バカにしてんじゃねーよ！！
[は] エイジ、風邪といえば何が大事でしょーか？
[エ] やっぱ、お薬とかじゃないすか？
[は] いや、そうなっちゃいますよね
[は] 結局、風邪をひくと何が大事かというと
[は] 栄養！栄養をとることがやっぱ大事なんで
[は] 今日は僕のこの風邪を治しつつ
[は] 栄養をとる動画をとろうと・・・
[リ・エ] （笑）
[は] んな、笑うなよぉー！！
[リ] マジメにやってます？（笑
[は] いや、ガチだからね
[は] サプリメントを何個か用意しました
[は] けっこうたくさんのサプリメントを準備したんですけども
[は] セントジョーンズソフト・・・
[は] 違うわ！全然違う！
[は] で、これらに共通していることは、全部、
[リ・エ] （笑）
[は] なんで笑う！？
[は] 全部ソフトカプセルなんですよ
[エ] いやー、もうやだー（笑
[は] 全部ソフトカプセルなんで
[は] 大きさが同じなんですよ、1回出してみましょう
[は] ソフトカプセルで大きさがほぼ一緒
[は] 違うのは微妙な色だけでございます
[は] このサプリメントを使って
[は] まあ僕くらいのサプリメントマスターになると
[は] サプリの味の微妙な違いまでわかります！
[は] なので、今日はこのサプリメントを使って
[は] 利きサプリメントをやってみようと思いまーす！！
[リ] バカげ・・・バカげてる（苦笑
[は] あの、ほんとに当てるから！
[リ] でもこれ当てられたら・・・
[は] いやー当てられたらホントすごいと思うよ
[は] というわけで、実際にやっていきましょう！
[は] まずは、味見からしていきましょう
[エ] 一通り全部食べるんすか？
[は] 一通り食べる
[エ] すごいな・・・
[は] 一通り食べて、味を覚えた後に
[は] 目隠しして、食べたやつが何かを当てます
[エ] なるほど
[エ] 名前だけで言ったらこれが一番おいしそうですよね
[は] ブルーベリーエキス・・・
[は] じゃ、まずブルーベリーエキス食べてみます
[は] いただきます
[は] 固い・・・
[は] ・・・！！！
[リ・エ] （笑）
[は] ンガッ！！
[エ] ベロやばいっすよ（笑
[は] 苦ぁ・・・！
[は] あああああ、苦っ！はぁ・・・
[は] ブルーベリーエキスはわかった
[は] 苦い中でもほのかにブルーベリー感があった
[エ] ああ、なるほどなるほど
[は] じゃ次、DHA食べてみます！
[リ] 大丈夫なのかな、コレ・・・
[エ] DHA食べるとか
[リ] すごいよね・・・
[は] DHAは味がない、うん
[は] DHAは味がない、意外とわかりやすい、こっちは
[は] じゃ次、マルチビタミン食べてみます！
[は] いただきます
[は] うぉぉぉお・・・！！
[リ・エ] （笑）
[は] ああやばい！ほんとに今なにこれ・・・
[は] マルチビタミンはブルーベリーエキスより苦い
[エ] あー、なるほど
[は] こっちがいま一番苦い
[エ] 苦さで比べるみたいな
[は] 苦さ、苦さは1つの基準になるかもね
[エ] ダイエットに効くみたいな
[は] あ、ダイエットか、ダイエット系のやつね
[は] メリロート！食べてみようと思います
[は] ！！！！
[エ] これは、これは今までで一番早い！！
[は] はあっ！はあっ！！
[リ] ああ！口ん中みえないように！！グロい！グロい！
[は] マジでやばい！！
[エ] 一番すか？
[は] 一番！メリロート一番タチ悪い！
[エ] これけっこう面白いっすね（笑
[は] これすごいよ、鳥肌たってるもん、ほら・・・
[リ] ホントだ！
[は] 次はちょっと、お肌に良さそうなヒアルロン酸
[は] うんうん、これは普通
[は] 気持ち苦い・・・気持ち苦いぐらい
[は] 濃縮ウコン食べてみます！いただきます
[は] んー！ウコンはそんなに
[は] あーでもやっぱウコンみたいな味はする
[は] わかりやすいです、ウコンは
[は] じゃ最後こちら、セントジョーンズワート
[は] これ何なの？
[リ] 気持ちを明るくする・・・
[エ] いやいやいや、ヤバいでしょ、もう絶対（笑
[は] ドラッグじゃねえか！！
[は] いただきます！
[は] ・・・・・・
[は] あああああっ！！！
[は] フゥーッ！フゥーッ！
[は] 痛い！
[リ・エ] 痛い！？
[は] 個性的だから、わかりやすいかもしんない
[は] はい、というわけで、一応ひと通り食べたので
[は] だいたいコツはわかりました
[は] どれがどんな味するかは大体わかったので
[は] 実際に目隠しして、この俺が
[は] どのサプリメントかを当てようと思います！
[は] 来いやー！！
[は] よろしくお願いします
[リ・エ] よろしくお願いします
[エ] やっぱりクセが強いやつはすぐバレちゃうから
[エ] コレかコレか、コレかな？
[エ] コレ・・・この辺じゃない？
[リ] だとしたら、コレでいいかな？
[エ] これでいきましょう！これでいきます！
[は] おし！！
[は] （パクパク）
[リ] もう入れましたよ
[は] え・・・？ウソじゃん！
[エ] 入ってますよ
[は] 入ってないよ！入ってないって！
[エ] 入れましたよ
[は] どこー？いやホントにわかんない、ホントにわかんない
[リ] 入れまーす！
[は] 入ったー？
[リ・エ] 入りました
[は] では・・・噛みます！
[は] メリロート！！メリロート！！
[は] ヴォェー！！メリロート・・・！！
[は] メリロート！正解は？
[リ・エ] 正解、正解でーす！！
[リ・エ] ああああ！！